boa tarde
é um prazer imenso estar aqui com vocês
hoje eu quero começar esse encontro
fazendo o que eu faço mais regularmente
há mais tempo
eu quero contar histórias pra vocês hoje
na verdade meu ofício como professora e
escritora envolve isso né mas esse é um
ofício que vocês sabem ele todos nós
eliminar essa história pela qual vou
começar lá existe
possivelmente há uns três mil anos dois
mil e oitocentos anos algo assim
essa história foi escrita por um foi
escrito não foi contado em primeiro
lugar por um escravo que era propriedade
de um filósofo e esses escravos chamava
esopo essa história atravessou os tempos
da grécia antiga
essa história chegou à europa no século
a europa do século 17 e foi criada por
jean de la fontaine na tradução do
ferreira gullar que é mais ou menos
assim tendo a cigarra cantado ao longo
de todo o verão
viu-se ao chegar o inverno sem nenhuma
provisão foi à casa da formiga sua amiga
e então ele disse a amiga pode emprestar
meu grão que seja de arroz de farinha ou
de feijão que estou morrendo de fome há
mais tempo então que não come
ele perguntou a formiga agora de
profissão faz e ao longo do verão o que
fez a senhora eu cantava pois tam se
agora bem essa história assim traduzido
inverso pelo jogo de ontem
é uma história que até hoje me toca
muito mexe muito com as coisas que eu
penso sobre valores sobre princípios e
isso faz isso certamente aconteceu com
muitos de nós e com outros escritores
o pioneiro da nossa literatura para
crianças e jovens monteiro lobato
antes de escrever
o seu projecto mais lembrado mais
contundente lindo que é o sítio do
picapau amarelo
ele descreve uma carta para um amigo
gustavo rangel e diz assim estou
pensando em investir a brasileira
aquelas fábulas de esopo ela foi ontem
estou pensando nisso porque meus filhos
eu vejo com meus filhos eles são tocados
pela forma como por ese a mulher jogou
barato conta essas histórias para eles
mas eles efetivamente eles num momento
algum eles pensam em nas modalidades
isso fica no subconsciente deles no
entanto essas fábulas eles guardam elas
de memória eles vão contar os amigos e
eles efetivamente não não percebem que a
modalidade está lá mas ela toca eles
profundamente como tocou lobato e ele
então escreve essa fábula reescreve ela
antes bens bem antes escreveu o sítio do
picapau amarelo ea versão do lobato ela
tem uma coisa um pouco diferente das
versões antigas ele ele cria uma formiga
boa
ele cria uma formiga que acolhe a
cigarra quando o cigarro pede então a
comida é uma ajuda do outro lado ele
encontra uma formiga que diz então era
senhora que cantava ao longo do verão
aqueles chiado nos distrair nos aliviava
do trabalho e aquilo era maravilhoso
bem eu tô contando essa história pra
vocês porque eu sou um pouco de garra e
da uerj é um pouco a casa dessa formiga
por que me acolheu desde sempre
aqui eu fui recebido como aluno de
graduação como aluno do mestrado em
letras doutorado em letras
aqui eu fui estagiário voluntário aqui
eu fui bolsista
aqui eu fui professor substituto e
finalmente o concurso e como professor
do curso de relações públicas da
faculdade de comunicação social
e aí eu comecei a pensar em outras
questões que me remetem sempre a cigarra
ea formiga
entre essas questões está a chamada
ética organizacional
a idéia de que você tenha um fábula como
essa para despertar o teu a tua cabeça
tua do pensamento nos leva a ver duas
situações possíveis numa situação
a gente tem no formiga que é vista como
sabe dedicada histórica e uma cigarra
que de alguma forma têm um trabalho
artístico dela completamente
desvalorizado na versão do lobato você
tem uma outra forma de ver essa coisa
uma visão que percebe que é possível uma
harmonia entre as duas visões de mundo e
eu não posso falar disso e falar de
ética sem a gente entender que ética tem
a ver com isso com as visões de mundo
que nós carregamos com isso que faz com
que a gente aprenda a interagir uns com
os outros e a lidar com o que a gente
chama de realidade continuamente e é
nesse plano que de alguma forma a
acertar reformista me devolvem a esse
lugar aonde os valores que nós temos
tem origem no que a gente chama de
costumes
a própria palavra ética meus caros ela
vende ethos que no grego tem a ver com
isso
os costumes são os costumes de um povo
que determina o que é o certo eo que é
errado
e de repente a gente se dá conta de que
esses valores esses costumes
eles vão se reproduzido nos nossos atos
todo dia que a gente talvez não pare pra
pensar um pouquinho sobre afinal de
contas o que entendemos com certo e
errado afinal de contas o que é o nosso
costume bem quando a gente fala então de
ética e eu não poderia falar de ética
aqui pra vocês eu ficaria até a manhã
conversando sobre o tema que foi tantas
vezes investigado por e proposto de
maneiras diferentes por filósofos
pensadores os mais variados aristóteles
scut
enfim tanta gente e eu não não tem essa
pretensão mas quando a gente fala sobre
ética numa organização
aí eu tenho essa pretensão porque aí eu
acho que essa tem que ser a nossa
pretensão se queremos responder à
pergunta o que nos faz universidade
a pergunta que mobiliza esse evento
ela é alta mel só pode ser respondida se
a gente em algum momento para pensar o
que é a nossa ética o que são os nossos
costumes
quais são os nossos valores a gente não
consegue responder essa pergunta sim
isso de repente a gente repete saída da
fábula da cigarra e da formiga ver esse
prédio e chega a essa definição um
conjunto de valores e princípios que
norteiam a ação humana no âmbito das
organizações
a definição do professor e filósofo
mário sérgio cortella
isso faz a gente pensar que esses
valores e princípios estão sendo
praticados pela gente e às vezes a gente
não está se dando conta do quanto eles
interferem nesse dia a dia é quando
então eu penso que a ética no plano de
uma comunidade no plano da nossa ação
diária cotidiana ela é o tempo todo
testada
pensem por exemplo o sujeito que está
andando de carro e amparado por um
guarda uma blitz uma coisa assim ele
pode ter algum problema no carro ele
pode ter furado o sinal vermelho e pode
ter cometido alguma falta
se existe algo errado tico é o ser
humano
ele erra o tempo todo no que ele erra
ele se vê diante do guarda e ele tem a
opção de aceitar a multa ou
eventualmente ele pensa eu posso dar uma
propina para esse guarda e ele me
liberar ninguém vai saber disso
é claro que para vários de vocês e pra
mim também isso é altamente condenável
mas é claro que isso se reproduz
diariamente nas estradas e nas vias nas
ruas brasileiras
e quando o sujeito que da propina por
guarda faz isso ele não se dá conta de
que o ato dele não acaba ali ele tem a
sensação de que talvez o ato dele seja
visível para o resto
porque só quem sabe foi ele é ele e
aguarda mas não porque o outro cara
pensa isso em um outro carro faz isso e
um terceiro e um quarto e um quinto e o
mesmo guarda que recebeu propina de não
sei quantas pessoas um dia se depara com
alguém que não quer da propina
e esse alguém talvez agora esteja numa
situação em que o errado é ele
mas peraí que tem alguma coisa
equivocada nessa história
se um costume de oferecer propina para
um oficial da lei se criou se esse
costume eu não estou dizendo nem que foi
criado que não foi não quero generalizar
mas na minha hipótese é se isso acontece
com um hábito com regularidade
o sujeito que não dá ele passa pelo que
ele passa por trouxa e quando ele é um
trouxa
parece que o certo eo errado se
inverteram e o que determina isso vocês
podem dizer não é só a lei é uma ética é
um conjunto de valores que estão sendo
praticados em momento algum eu disse
aqui vocês que esses valores vão ser
sempre os melhores
há momentos em que a humanidade seguia
por valores rochosos
a gente não tem como fugir disso ou
melhor a gente tem a gente tem como
fugir disso
porque o que nos torna universidade nos
faz pensar que esses atos que hoje
parecem tão singular estão individuais
que acabam em si
eles não são então se você se cada um de
vocês que está aqui hoje nessa platéia
pensar sobre isso não apenas aqui na
universidade
alguns estudam em outras universidades
alguns ainda vão estudar alguns já
estudaram mas o que nos torna
universidade entre outras coisas é a
capacidade de refletir sobre o que são
os nossos costumes
se eu sair do plano macro e enviar o
plano mais micro do que a nossa
realidade aqui eu posso pensar num
agente governamental no governante que
neste momento cogita não pagar salário
para os professores para os técnicos
administrativos para os bolsistas
não pagar remuneração para os bolsistas
porque o estado não tem dinheiro e cria
se então um precedente para a gente
achar que isso não é tão errado assim
bem daqui a 20 30 anos quando novos
governantes fizerem isso talvez não
sejamos mais universidade ea implicação
do ato desse governante agora se faz
sentir muito tempo depois o funcionário
que chega atrasado e saiu mais cedo o
funcionário que faz uma escala e foge do
trabalho um dia 2 e ele pensa que talvez
a falta dele aqui ou não está ali não é
um problema porque afinal de contas um
outro está lá e não tem implicação
sempre têm implicação
só que nós não aprendemos a ver nós
precisamos aprender a ver o professor
o professor que recebe uma ementa de uma
disciplina e foge de cimento e opto por
entrar em sala de aula e abordar o tema
que lhe é mais caro que ele está mais
confortável por favor
ele não percebe a implicação do seu ato
na vida do outro
todos esses atos todas essas atitudes
envolvem uma reflexão sobre ética e
nesse caso o aluno
o aluno que copia um trabalho não vocês
eu sei que vocês não
mas o aluno que chega atrasado
sai mais cedo o aluno que falta como
professor muitos muitas vezes nas
primeiras aulas de cada semestre
eu tive que explicar para os alunos
porque eu fazia foi com ele cobrava
freqüência e o porque que eu era tão
chato com esse negócio
e aí quando o aluno já estava com aquela
cara de péssima de 15 sem impor mas não
vou conseguir aqui sempre o que eu faço
eu olhava para ele dizendo assim cara
quando você falta você me privada do
direito de ouvir você ea aula é pior
porque ela não pode ser esse lugar em
que só eu falo e os alunos escutam
é preciso que a gente troca idéia é
preciso que ele fale para que o outro
cara fala e também porque
acordem e aí quando ele falta ele tem
uma implicação ética
ele produz uma implicação ética na vida
do outro só que ele talvez não perceba
e aí é isso que eu quero convidar vocês
a pensar hoje porque a bem da verdade
quando a gente reflete sobre como uma
ética atravessa tudo
quando a gente na verdade coloca em
questão os nossos costumes e porque é
que eles se tornaram costumes
então a gente precisa refletir para
mudar a gente precisa refletir para
repensar a gente precisa refletir para
melhorar
sem isso num todas as outras questões me
parecem menores porque nós somos
universidade a partir do momento que
temos essa capacidade a capacidade de
mudar de repensar a capacidade de
melhorar a coisa maravilhosa da frase de
monteiro lobato para o senhor para o seu
amigo que estava gel é a moralidade está
lá na fábula mas o menino não percebe
ela fica no subconsciente pra esse
revelando aos poucos eu convido vocês a
repensarem a mudarem
mas mais que tudo a refletirem sobre
ética porque isso não pode ficar no
plano do nosso subconsciente isso tem
que estar no plano do nosso consciente
diariamente todo dia em cada ato que a
gente produz não pensa no ato do outro
pensa no seu e na implicação que pode
ter na vida do outro isso é uma postura
de quem busca um equilíbrio ético e uma
harmonia numa sociedade especialmente
numa universidade
na verdade o que nós temos mais bonito
aqui não é ge é uma condição cultural
muito diversa é uma condição étnica
política social histórica maravilhosa
isso de verdade é o que faz com que a
gente tenha mais chance de sair desse
lugar
de de não reflexão para chegar a esse
outro lugar de pensar o que é a ética em
relação a cada pequeno ato individual
eu quero convidar todos vocês então a
pensarem sobre os atos que têm no dia a
dia dessa universidade no dia a dia na
vida em sociedade e por isso agradeço
muitíssimo a todos vocês
obrigado boa tarde
[Aplausos]